aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée nationale une
proposition de loi de la majorité est
examinée son objectif rendre obligatoire
les drapeaux français et européens et
moi je suis sûr que aucune voie de la
majorité ne manquera sur ce texte qui
est un texte symbolique et symbolique ne
veut pas dire anecdotique la politique
ce sont aussi des symboles oui c'est une
façon d'affirmer qu'on est pro-europea
donc on est pour la paix qu'on est pour
le travail ensemble et encore beaucoup
de choses à faire en Europe y compris
l'Europe sociale y compris l'Europe des
gens vous croyez que les gens voient pas
ce qui se passe en Europe et parce qu'on
va mettre un drapeau ça je veux dire
c'est le niveau intellectuel de
renaissance aujourd'hui c'est à dire
qu'on fait de la politique un truc mais
on ne fait rien d'efficace indemnité
fiscale et civique
pour des personnages comme des sportifs
c'est l'exemplarité aujourd'hui
de la participation de l'équipe de
France ça ne sert à rien je veux dire
c'est déjà présent sur l'essentiel des
mairies de France à quoi bon aller
rajouter un sujet sur un sujet qui n'en
est pas un j'ai deux éléments en tête
qui viennent Karim Benzema dont on me
dit qu'il paie ses impôts en France et
je me réjouis et puis l'équipe de France
de tennis dont beaucoup étaient domicile
en Suisse puis ils n'ont plus le droit
de représenter la France mais je pense
que ça serait une vraie vertu
d'exemplarité le gouvernement a présenté
ce matin son plan de lutte contre la
fraude fiscale des très gros fraudeurs
dorénavant et ces derniers pourront être
privés de leur droit civique pendant
plusieurs années et perdre le bénéfice
de tout crédit d'impôt je veux
concentrer les efforts sur le haut du
spectre sur les plus grands schémas de
fraude les plus élaborés ceux qui
souvent ont une implication
internationale et évidemment alléger
aussi la pression sur les classes
moyennes les patrons de PME
500 agents supplémentaires vont être
affectés à cette tâche dont une centaine
qui sont qualifiées d'agents d'élite du
renseignement fiscal ils pourront
utiliser les écoutes téléphoniques ou
bien la pose de balise GPS pour traquer
les fraudeurs
à l'étranger quand il y a bande organisé
je considère qu'on est plus dans la
citoyenneté et qu'on doit être privé
pour un ton de tout accès à réduction
d'impôts crédit d'impôts et à ses droits
civiques dont son droit de vote vous
allez adorer le service de
renseignements fiscal avec ces agents
secrets c'est détectives publics ces
gorges profondes une centaine de James
Bond du fisc seront recrutés avant la
fin du quinquennat il
rémunéreront leurs sources qui
travaillent dans de grandes banques dans
des entreprises du CAC 40 ou chez des
avocats fiscalistes
un slogan revendiqué par des
organisations fascistes scandés par 5 à
700 personnes habillées tout en noir
dans les rues de Paris des drapeaux avec
la croix celtique symbole de l'extrême
droite radical il y a un droit à
manifester qui est garanti et qu'on ne
peut
revenir sur ce droit que quand il y a
des bonnes raisons qui sont énumérées
dans la loi leur public c'est quoi c'est
un risque d'affrontement la commission
de violence de dégradation et en plus il
y a une deuxième condition il faut que
je démontre que je ne suis pas en
capacité avec les forces de l'ordre
placées sous mon autorité de contenir
ces troubles quelle est la polémique
dans la polémique parmi les manifestants
deux anciens trésoriés de Marine Le Pen
ce ne sont pas mes amis se défendent
intéressés je souhaiterais faire marqué
la présence dans ce cortège dans Sean
trésorier du micro-partie de Madame Le
Pen que des membres du groupe Union
défense et des ex doivent Paris je
considère que ces provocations ne
peuvent pas être tolérée quel que soit
le camp dont c'est provocations émane
cette inadmissible mais ce n'est pas
parce que l'ennemi est silencieux et
marche pas sans déborder qu'il n'est pas
dangereux l'identité du lanceur de
peinture est révélé il s'agit de Pierre
Chassin un ancien élu du Front national
des Yvelines moi j'ai un profond dégoût
pour ces groupuscules d'extrême droite
pour les idées qui véhiculent
la ministre de la Culture fait alors le
lien entre les coûts du RN contre le
tableau et la dégradation faite dimanche
par un ancien du parti
décidément Marine Le Pen rien n'a changé
depuis le Front national le fils aîné
d'Éric Zemmour est mise en examen et
placée sous contrôle judiciaire de puis
hier il est accusé d'avoir provoqué un
grave accident il a percuté un scooter
et blessé gravement deux personnes alors
qu'ils conduisaient à vivre allure et
sous l'emprise de l'alcool